- I am so good at getting
eight hours of sleep, man.
How many hours of sleep you get baby?
- [Voiceover] I don't know like six?
- Oh yeah, that's it?
Babe don't worry about it I'm gonna
make coffee it's gonna be great.
I made a cup of coffee
for Zack the other day,
he said it was better than Starbucks.
And that's his words not mine.
Oh this guy wants to race hunh?
Woo.
Not today, not today, Nascar baby.
Woo look at that, look how close that is.
Ooh, ooh, get on my level Joe, get on it.
- Great job everyone, but I
want to give a shout out to Ned.
- I don't take this for granted.
I know this is the fifth time you've
given me a shout out this quarter.
Only four for Shane, sorry Shane.
Hopefully some day Eli and Steve
can get to even Shane numbers, maybe.
But when you get there
remember where you came from.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I beat you.
What type of dressing did you get?
- Like medium amount.
- I go the light dressing so
my salads technically healthier.
So I won lunch.
Oh nice shot.
- Yeah.
- [Ned] Nice, okay okay.
Let me try, let me try.
- Oh, dude.
- Boom hit it.
- Gotcha right there.
- No, I'll try it again,
let me try it again.
Dig it.
Laser.
- You're wasting foil now.
- One more.
Woo.
- Yeah.
- [Ned] Woo.
How many of those do you think I hit?
- Like one.
- Yes, yes, yes, boom.
Inbox zero baby, yes.
How many, how many you have?
What wow, wow, who, who, hah.
- Hell yeah.
- Damn it.
- [Voiceover] Alright thanks fellas.
- [Ned] Thank you.
- Yes, thanks.
- Alright, appreciate it.
Alright, how much we tipping here?
You only tipping 20%?
- [Voiceover] Hey Ned, would
you mind taking out the trash?
- Oh, I actually already did it earlier.
- [Voiceover] Great, thank
you, I'll be in soon.
- Okay.
Aw, such a proud Ned day.
Probably the best actually.
I'm not too competitive,
I'm just good baby.
Lebron.